The joe rogan experience.
And when you structure your stories,
do you use a software program
to use index cards on a,
a bulletin board?
Like how do you set up where you're moving
all your pieces in your tetris game?
I used to things we do use,
I got a,
uh,
magnetic whiteboard in the office and
write on the index cards and put them all
up with that.
And sometimes,
you know,
strings between the cards,
that kind of thing.
That's the general getting
it all down the flow.
And then I use a program called scrivener,
which people can use for Mac or PC.
And it's basically the same thing.
It's little index cards in the
computer and there's an index card that
represents a document,
each document as a chapter.
But it's great.
It's better than Microsoft
word because Microsoft word,
once you get a bit pass a hundred pages,
200 pages,
you're copping big chunks and moving
around and it becomes a nightmare cause
you're gonna screw something up.
But Scribner,
he's grabbed this icon and
drag it before this icon.
It rearranges everything.
So I've gotten pretty adept at using that.
A highly recommend it.
It's great for scatterbrain
to keep everything flowing.
And then a lot of times it'll just be,
you know,
I get overwhelmed with the screen and
everything going on and I'll just pull out
the three by five index cards and
start writing everything down again,
bullet points and those put them up on
the board and go through it that way.
So you like to do it digitally,
you like to do it manually,
you like to just mix it up and constantly
keep doing it in a different way that
keeps your brain moving?
Yeah.
What I find is when you get stuck,
there's a couple of different things.
Number one,
if you just staring at that screen,
you're stuck.
Just getting your hands
involved and a pen and I,
you know,
like just an ink pen and paper
is a tactile experiences,
different experience.
It activates different parts of
your brain sometimes can like,
oh now I get it,
now I see what I was stuck on.
So that's part of it.
And other parts of it is either,
there's only so much screen real estate,
so you can only see so
many things at one time.
If you're really stuck,
you pull back,
right?
All these index cards,
you put it up in this,
you know,
four foot by five foot whiteboard and
you kind of look at everything that can
spring your brain free at times too.
So it's largely,
it's grabbing whatever's,
if I get stuck in one area,
I'll start going to other areas and um,
when I get really
overwhelmed and frustrated,
I am more comfortable slipping back into,
you know,
the eight year old version of me,
which is a little piece of paper and some
notes or an index card and go back and
just ride it out until it
all kind of flows out of it.
So as long as the process is just
continuing over and over and over again,
yeah,
that's a scrivener.
Yup.
Yeah,
I use that for jokes I used.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I use it.
I use a,
a couple of different things.
One,
I use a real chalkboard or
real a corkboard rather.
And I have index cards and I put
'em up with pins and I have bits.
I have a one star,
two star and three star.
One star is a completely new bit,
two stars a bit.
That's still improving.
Three stars is a bit,
that's pretty close to being done.
They always grow and change and get weird.
And there's always like new
directions they take on certain shows.
And because I mixed them up too,
I'll mix up the order of like the
different pieces inside the bit to try to
figure out which way works.
And I liked scrivener because could take
those cards and just move them around.
And sometimes when I'm just studying,
just thinking about my act,
maybe I'll listen to recordings.
It's one of the most
uncomfortable parts of standup.
But I think one of the most important,
you got to listen and see yourself,
um,
and,
and listened to like,
Ooh,
I don't like how I did that.
Like there's too much,
too much bullshit and that joke and
that this joke is Kinda clunky and the
wording's not good or the inflection
is too fake or what have you.
You know,
so,
uh,
that process is aided by that.
And one of the things that I really
love was going to ask you about is right
room ever.
He's right room.
I've used it just to
look on the phone now.
Right room is the one that takes your
entire screen and makes it black and gives
you that green tag that to you.
Oh does it really?
It's,
he's got a white out or
a blackout feature on,
I can get rid of everything on the
screen except what you're reading.
So kind of the same thing.
Oh,
okay,
cool.
Yeah.
Well that's a right room.
Doesn't give you access to anything.
You can't go to the tool bar.
You can say what time it is.
You don't get shit.
Yeah,
that's right.
Room.
That's what it looks like.
I really,
really like it.
It's my favorite.
I,
it's something I probably need to start
using more in scrivener because I get
distracted and trying to stay in touch
with social media and everything else.
And if you're on the computer
and a fan is asking a question,
the natural impulses to
go answer that question.
So,
you know,
getting to a point where I
can just ignore all that.
But um,
I was just in Vegas for the new media
expo and when I really get into it and I
was under deadline,
so I started writing at noon.
We were staying at the Rio,
don't have the seafood buffet at the rail.
I will tell you that.
How dare you.
Oh my God.
I said that the top,
the best vomit of my whole life
and has been a lot of vomiting,
clams and a musket.
Oh,
I don't even know.
I don't know what it was,
but it was,
it was Linda Blair shit.
It was crazy.
But I'm,
I'm writing and it's like noon out and
like there's the window and the window is
open and by the time I got finished
it looked out and it was pitch black
outside.
So sometimes I can't imagine it's the
same thing when you're writing more of the
short form jokes and moving
around from the jokes.
But for this long form
things like 50 page story,
I had my own screen came up and I,
that's all I was working on.
I didn't look at anything else.
Just wrote the whole thing through.
Yeah,
you can get in those zones.
I don't write jokes like joke jokes.
What I do is I write about subjects and
I find the jokes in what I write about
it when he went.
What I find is that when
I'm writing about things,
it takes longer for me to write the word
history then for me to think of it or
know it exists.
If I'm thinking about
history I can think about it.
But I have to say his tier.
I mean I have to actually individually
type all the letters and in that you,
you have much more consideration to
every sentence that you write every,
every chapter,
every concept.
Cause you're,
you're thinking a lot
quicker than your writing.
So as you're writing it down,
you're considering deeply each indivi.
It's like its forces you to pause
and consider each individual word.
Consider the,
the,
the concept of you're actually talking
about far more than if you were just
having a conversation.
You're having a conversation.
It takes more,
it takes,
it's much quicker to get the words right.
I think in that slowing you down,
it makes you consider things more and
then sometimes you'll just miss like
really obvious shit.
You would have missed
it if you were talking,
but when you're riding like,
oh,
and what about this?
And then you'll go off
in some other directions.
Like you give your brain
like a different rhythm.
The rhythm of writing.
No talking,
no,
no distractions,
no fucking music.
Stop all the nonsense.
Locked the door,
hit the right room and just go.
Yeah.
Do you find,
do you find you have to go for a certain
amount of time before all of a sudden
shit starts to take off?
I'm useless for the first half hour.
Yeah.
So let's ask some harder.
It was full of the word.
Sometimes I,
I don't even take credit for the things
I write because it's not me writing
them.
You know?
It's your inner,
your inner muse.
We'd wrote it.
We wrote that one.
No,
I don't know how that one in me,
I'm like,
the first 30 minutes
are usually just trash,
absolute trash work,
and then at some point something just
takes over and you're making really good
stuff.
It's interesting,
isn't it,
that that weird switch that goes off
where you find yourself really zen in what
you're doing?
For me,
it is probably around the same time,
about 30 minutes in 2030 minutes.
The first 20 minutes just,
I don't even think,
I'm just trying to smash keys and
write things down and just thinking,
but just kind of getting
into it and trying to,
and then somewhere along
the line he catch traction.
My add so bad.
Now I've got a technique like I'll just
set the alarm on the phone instead of 30
minutes and then I'm like,
okay,
I'm just not going to
look at anything else.
I can do this for 30 minutes.
It's just 30 minutes that bad.
Yeah,
it's bad.
Force yourself to write for 30 minutes.
Doesn't matter what you write.
And then almost invariably by
the time the buzzer goes off,
you're just like turn it
off and you're just like,
cause you're,
you're rolling at that point.
But you have to force yourself to be
like a half to get into the groove.
My groove is usually also
to move around the house.
I like to pick up my laptop
and go sit somewhere else,
go sit in my uh,
you know,
sit in my living room,
go sit upstairs,
go sit in front of the TV.
You don't even watch TV.
Just sit on the couch.
You know?
I think that when I do that,
instead of just being in my office and
stare at the screen and sometimes just
being in a different space,
sitting in a different place to go,
oh,
we're here now and that just
that changing of your routine,
just a little variation on it
sometimes can spark the mind.
An interesting new direction you get.
You get down these wormholes and just
getting any other kind of sensory input,
which goes back to now I'm going to write
things down and said a type them out
or anything like that can
cause it's all in there.
All that stuff you want to
come up with is in there.
It's not like you're,
you know,
it's not like you have a factory
where you have to make all this crap.
It's all already in there.
You just kind of getting,
figuring out how to mine it out of your
own brain and put it onto the page.
You know what I also
find super beneficial.
A Walk,
a walk.
Yeah.
Walk,
you know,
and uh,
used to bring a recorder but
now with these new cell phones,
you don't have to use your phone can
record amazing notes and I just go for a
walk,
walk my dogs or something like that,
go down the street.
And just when I'm thinking about something
and I've got something in my head and
I'm done writing and then I'm reviewing
the things that I wrote and like how
would I,
how would I view this if I
was a person who reading it?
Like how would I,
how would I take this?
Like I'll,
I'll take it into
consideration as I'm walking.
It's like the fat,
you know,
there's something about forcing
yourself to do a mundane,
very obvious task,
left foot,
right foot,
and then you can get into that
groove of introspective thought.
Yeah.
And it does,
some of that to me is like,
I've,
I've got this little tiny office,
but there's like a loop.
There's like four rooms and you actually
go from kitchen to this room to the
entryway to the writing room.
And I just,
I just start doing labs.
And it usually doesn't take very long
because you're turning right all the time,
every two steps.
And it's,
there's something about your brain has
to put some level of attention on it,
not walking into things.
And that usually comes from
the part that's blocking you.
The part that stopped me.
Like you're convincing yourself,
you can't get this shit out and now.
Okay.
Oh,
all right.
Boom that run back to the desk and
start writing similar things down really
quick.
Have you ever tried using speech
recognition software for writing
wouldn't work for me only because I'm,
by the time I block a sentence down,
it's probably already be written.
Been rewritten three times.
Start a sentence,
go back,
start sentence,
go back.
And unfortunately a pretty fast typer.
I learned that a long time ago is
I knew I wanted to write and yeah,
I just changed things.
Sell fast.
Like it's all muscle memory now.
It's like copy this,
paste this,
move this around.
I,
I cannot imagine speech
recognition would ever work for me.
The um,
uh,
Mavis Bacon teaches typing.
That's the one I owe.
I owe that Mavis Bacon.
She looked me up.
Yeah,
that was a for me man.
I was the poker guy.
Yeah.
This looking right at them.
It took a long time.
Genius product.
Like,
no,
just play video games pitch and like what?
I'm just playing video games
and all of a sudden I can type.
It was amazing.
It's amazing and it's their fun games
like you're racing and share what you're
doing.
All kinds of different stuff and
figuring out where the little keys are.
That's,
that's so important,
man.
I used to have one of
those goofy keyboards.
It was like separated split ones.
Yeah,
and your hands rest on it
and ship those tied off.
What happened is supposed to be working on
work for crap.
They're supposed to be good for you.
I had the one that actually
was like a transformer.
It actually had a hinge
when this thing was bad ass.
Did you ever get the
one where you sink in?
You sink your fingers in.
There was a weird one like this or
your fingers like sit in a cradle.
I still have to look
like every now and then I'm still
glancing down to get some kind of tracking
going on,
which I don't need to do any more,
but I can't break myself
of the habit like I can.
I can.
I do this.
Sometimes when I'm
overwhelmed with an idea,
I'll just close my eyes and just start
typing so I don't need to do it anymore,
but I'm still,
I can't break that habit of
looking down at the screen.
That's the thing.
Look at that.
Yeah.
I had one of those.
Yeah,
there was those and then there was the
Microsoft ones are a little bit more
curly and they had like an
actual space in between.
It didn't separate.
They're just,
it's more like lumpy.
They called them ergonomic
keyboards things anymore.
I don't think,
I don't know.
You know what the problem is?
You get used to those,
then you go to a laptop and it's,
it feels weird,
you know a lot of people are
typing their stuff on laptops now,
so like the way you learn how to type
on a laptop is you want your to be right
in that position of j and f the fingers
across the board and then from there you
go.
If you go back and forth
from laptop to keyboard,
this is like a thinking part where you
have to like a quarterback changing.
You're throwing lotion,
it's to change everything around.
Yeah.
It fucks with you.
But the speech recognition software is
fascinating to me because I wonder if
that I'll ever be something
that I'm interested in because,
uh,
for the walks,
I have to imagine,
you know,
right.
You're walking,
you still speak everything down.
No,
I just record it.
Right.
And Go back and listen to,
yeah.
I go back and listen to it.
I really find that there's a
completely different state of mind,
the actual writing state of mind,
and I find that I'm way more creative
when I could just sit in total silence,
not hear my voice or
anybody's voice and for right.
I allow,
allow my brain to go in all sorts of
weird directions when they're not,
it's not attached to flowing,
moving language.
Ideas can serve a merge instantaneously
and I just try to follow them and
capture them in writing.
I think a,
I limit myself when I'm actually talking.
Hmm.
Yeah.
You know,
it comes to writing things.
Yeah.
It,
it's for me,
but at this point it's just down to,
it's a process.
Now I've got the process going and
getting more and more comfort with the
process.
So hopefully I'm growing towards that.
You know,
Stephen King's process is just so fast
that your process is also very creative.
I mean,
you have to have this idea,
you have to have the story of to create
this story after that part's never
people.
Some people talking about writer's block,
I've never had that.
I've had the opposite,
which is just this on slot of cool ideas.
Like this would be a good book and this
be a good book and trying to try and
keep track of everything.
So the,
the creative part,
um,
being scatterbrained,
middle kid fortunately just
has never been an issue for me.
It's all it with me.
It's always been the discipline of being
able to write it down and trying to
fight the add and you know,
and like I have to keep working on
this to make it the best it can be.
When after the first draft,
I'm kind of already done with it.
I'm like,
ah,
I want to,
I want to go do something else.
But you can't,
you gotta go back and keep
hammering on that sword,
make it,
make it a good weapon.
Yeah,
that's,
that's really interesting that it's
the different types of creative
processes that all try to
achieve the same thing,
whether it's a song or
a movie or a book or,
or a joke.
It's this completely fascinating to me.
The different ways that people
approach it and different,
the different mindsets they
have in approaching it too.
Do
you know that there's,
there's no one pattern,
which is what's fascinating
about the human brain.
Everybody's got a different way of doing
it and just keep working at it till you
get to that end product and where you
can hopefully look at what you finished
with and I think all creative
people kind of have the same thing.
You probably have it too,
like that's a pretty good joke.
That's not the best it could possibly be,
but I think that's pretty good.
That's going to go in the arsenal
for the next stand up and with me,
it's like that book is pretty good.
I would work on that book
for the next 10 years.
Every day to try and
make everything perfect.
But you know,
at least for me,
there,
there is no perfection like,
and you hear some others go,
I keep working on until
I've absolutely the perfect,
the perfect phrase and a
perfect sentence in a perfect,
in the perfect page,
that's great.
But you know,
we got to put a book out and sell some
books so I can't work on a book for 10
years.
Okay.